normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government we've
talked a lot about Foreign Wars tonight
but we're in the middle of a war right
here at home it's a war not between
black and white or Democrat and
Republican it's between those of us who
believe in our founding ideals and love
this country and a fringe minority who
hates the United States of America and I
think it's going to take a commander and
chief to lead us to victory in that war
who first of all knows that we're in a
war second of all can't be captured by
the special interests along the way but
third is from the Next Generation
somebody with fresh legs to lead us to
Victory I'll shut down the Deep State
I'll declare economic independence from
China I'll keep us out of World War III
and then revive national pride in this
country I also want to close with one
message to the Democrat Party end this
farce that Joe Biden is going to be your
nominee yeah of the United States he's a
puppet for the managerial class so have
the guts to step up and be honest about
who you're actually going to put up we
have bid should step aside end his
candidacy now so we can see whether it's
Nome or Michelle Obama or whoever else
it's new but yes I agree very good they
in my I don't know he took out a lot of
a lot of them
tonight I don't know how it's going to
out is stuff but it really does seem
like he's got war in the Middle East
finger on
the floor it is very important that we
know how to defend our freedoms and how
to defeat terrorism and socialism we
have to know the difference between good
and evil we have to know the difference
between right and wrong we need to know
that a strong America doesn't start wars
a strong America prevents Wars and the
way we can focus on that is to make sure
we go back to the soul of America and be
strong and proud again and we can't do
that we can't win the fight
of the 21st century with politicians
from the 20th century we have to move
forward and we can do this I know we can
do this so join our movement go to
nikey.com and we will once again show
what America that's strong and proud
looks like God bless Ambassador thank
you no thank you yikes I'll pass on that
one she follows me on
Twitter maybe not after tonight she
think we'll interview all these like
interv ire leadership I will take the
hits I will take the arrows I will take
the barbs cuz it's not about me it's
about you it's not about the past it's
about your future we are going to fight
for you I am going to win for you and
your family and I'm going to lead this
country's Revival as a veteran of the
Iraq War and in the Navy I will always
put service above self as president as
the father of three young kids I'm going
to ensure that this country is left to
the the Next Generation in better shape
than we found it and as the governor of
Florida I delivered on all my promises
and you can trust me to deliver for you
as the President of the United States I
am asking for your vote I'll be a
nominee that will be able to win the
election I will be a leader you can be
proud of and as your president I will
not let you down God bless you Governor
Sanders thank
you is that
it Mr H going to out that
is that is going to conclude our all
right 95% save aake one he crushed Ron's
got 3% Nikki has got one and Chris has
got one uh I didn't exclude Tim Scott
from the poll to make like a dig at Tim
Scott it's just YouTube only allows four
categories it was pretty clear would it
say he had 1% too if Chris Chris Chris
Christie got
one look let me say uh I like Tim Scott
way more than Chris Christie way more
than Nikki Haley but he should not be on
a presidential debate stage it was like
he was thinking about what to say next
like his words were being like did you
notice that like what I no definitely
and I think he forgot some stuff you
know it was just I don't think he was
fully prepared for some of those
questions he's an emotional uh like the
appeal to emotion to like he's taking
yeah his time with every word that he
says so it means I think it's the wrong
time in history for that too because
people have less and less attention spin
like even myself I know when watching
videos or podcasts or whatever I turn it
on to where it's one and a half times as
fast yeah I'm listening way faster than
I ever have in my life a lot of people
are in the same boat so when you hear
somebody talking really slowly like this
it starts to feel like they don't know
what they want to say oh I've noticed
that on this show as a co-host cuz Tim
will talk really fast and then if I come
in like this everyone's like shut up
shut up it's like no no talk faster get
it out of way everybody says that about
you Ian like I I didn't want to tell you
but it's it's been a big conversation
you know behind your back I'm just Kidd
we're going to read some super chats so
we're not going to have a members on the
uncensored show tonight because it was a
debate night and uh you know they go
long so uh we're just going to read
super chats and YouTube's been doing
this weird thing where it's not loading
properly yeah I know what's going on so
I didn't refresh so we got uh the first
few super chats here we started a little
early Clint Tores says howdy people hey
Clint Clint with the first Super Chat
look at me says I'm the captain now well
maybe maybe number one look at me all
right and uh here we go C Lux production
say anyone who raises a foreign nation's
flag at her capital in front of the
White House should be considered
traitors only the American flag should
be uh W should wave there period right
on interesting we're gonna we're going
to refresh it and hopefully get all of
the super chats to load now without um
because it cuts off the early ones when
we reload it yo uh VI's debate
performance may be the best debate
performance I have ever seen he pulled a
Bill Clinton like like Clinton in his
first debate was lame and then came in
and he must have had great review of his
own performance and came in and just
smashed it in 1992 and now that's
similar to what VI did I don't know that
you'll ever beat that moment where Trump
said because you'd be in jail so good
that's true that's a tough one to be but
I mean like holistically like from start
to finish let's just say that V had the
low blow Haymakers to Donald Trump's
massive jab right in knock out the only
way you could do totally better is if
you pulled the same thing and you
actually put her in jail you know that
would be in Improvement however hard to
beat that moment I think it's I mean
honestly Jesse uh Kelly was talking or
was tweeting today he said something
about talking about Trump and it's his
opinion that Trump's going to go to jail
and I think that he's probably right I
agree and I don't know if I don't know
if there's normies that are going to
vote for uh you know a president that's
in jail I think there are oh I don't
think that there I don't think there's
enough to get over the to get him over
well I mean it'll be it'll be the Pres
it'll be Donald Trump versus whoever and
I would I would personally prefer to see
someone like V in the
spot because he's not in jail than to
see Donald Trump running from jail if
Donald Trump doesn't go to jail then I
think that Donald Trump has a better
shot I think if Donald Trump does go to
jail I think that that just puts normies
off because there's so many normies
they're just not smart enough he went to
jail like Vote for This is not this is
not a this is not my preference I'm just
saying that this is this is what it
seems most likely to me we have and a
correction too it was the stream that we
had of trump had 7,700 Okay cool so uh
Delmar says Trump had 130k and the
debate had 70 I wonder how he how that's
but I think I think the issue is are we
combining everything are you talking
about like Trump Trump's core stream cuz
we had Trump Junior's Channel and it
wasn't loading properly right
yeah all right super dank says D santis
is the heel and V is the baby face this
is a WWE match
correct I mean that's pretty much all of
politics at this point Dave Ruben
tweeted that VI is such an insufferable
prick and he's getting ratioed really
really hard for it hard look man W dude
I just Ruben just got baited into giving
VI a lot of PL a lot of uh no I think I
think the people who who hitch their
wagon to Ronda santis are probably
sweating bullets well you've got to be
kind of upset with these performances
and also so you know I mean Dave's a
smart guy I think that he knows deep
down the campaign has not been run the
way that it should have been run if you
really wanted to have a great shot here
VI on the other hand has set himself up
well whether it's his teams doing or his
own I don't know but somebody there has
set himself up well in the event that
something does happen with President
Trump you know because I think a lot of
the people who support Trump are going
to shift that direction should something
like that happen unless it's somebody
who comes in late you know I don't know
if they'll be able to get on the ballot
though in that case you know so there's
a lot up in the air but I do know that
the way they've run the campaign they're
not set up well to take in Trump voters
in any event yeah you know it's just
there's a lot of hard feelings and stuff
and I don't think it's going to turn out
well and I think if you're somebody who
hitched yourself really early on to Ron
you're probably upset by the way things
have been run and it makes you a little
more testy with situations like this I
think that's another strong point with v
is V has because he's not attacking
Trump everyone kind of feels like he's
the guy that's like he's he's maybe he's
going for VP or whatever um or whatever
you know your your prediction might want
to be but because of his take on Trump
and because he's been very you know
passive towards Trump he leaves the door
open for all the Trump voters that if
they're not going to vote for Trump and
Trump's you know I talked before about
Trump's floor it's very very solid there
are dieh hard his bottom is solid his
bottom is solid yes but yes but because
of that if Trump isn't in the running
it's very easy for those people to slide
over into VES camp and because of the
fact that V what V is talking about is
very similar to Trump's policies they're
not there's not a lot of daylight
between them um and I think that the is
probably more informed on the policies
than Trump is much the IES but more
eloquently stated you know so like it's
like it was a hard sell to sell Trump
policies to let say somebody who went to
an Ivy League or somebody who was in a
tech startup that is you know doing some
Innovative thing vivate can communicate
to those people the exact same policy
that they just scoffed at and treated
like it was crazy coming from Trump they
hear it from him and they go oh that's
really smart and it's it's not a
byproduct of somehow the policy gets
better it's just that the communication
is clear to that person but meanwhile VI
he's also still communicating to your
typical Trump Bas voter like like me you
know like I voted for Trump both times I
fully understand in the same way in
respect that I did with Trump and I
think that's why he pulls in some
interesting different people that were
pushed away maybe by Trump in the
beginning so it's interesting but I mean
Trump is obviously still the leader I
don't I don't think he's going to prison
in a way that would prevent him from
being able to become president let read
this from uh Char DEET he says I'm
pro-life but I also believe in choice
for others God gives all mankind Free
Will and I think we can have our own
beliefs and values uh what did it say
butt bits up to but but it's I see the B
was a was an accidental type Meant to
hit the space bar to each individual uh
I completely
disagree you cannot have one state being
like it's not murder if you kill a
person from this background it's not
murder you can't have that you can't
have one state be like we think this is
is not a person it's like are they a
person or not answer the question yeah
I'm looking at natural person it's the
natural person cuz there are other
persons they're corporations but if it
are babies at two months in the womb
considered natural persons legally
that's really what it comes down to
federal government needs to have an
answer for that and uh my attitude is
yeah I'm I I'm not traditional pro-life
I'm traditional pro-choice and um while
I think abortion is wrong I think
there's very difficult constitutional
questions and how you balance the rights
of two individuals sharing one body and
then ultimately I just want to uh
encourage Democrats to get the abortions
they want to get uh uh you know
Democrats and liberals and leftists you
know I will I will help facilitate uh
their their uh trips and see I don't
want them to get abortions I want their
kids to to find a different pathway than
their parents did thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 800m and become a member over
at
timcast.net uncensored membersonly shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time